[Music]
all right welcome to mastering the
middlegame so we have to dumb down the
lecture for obvious reasons no not
because of the audience although that's
because I'm a grandmaster so I have to
play like a master so I can show lots of
my games since I've been playing badly
lately today we're going to look at one
of my games but not the whole game
because then you'd leave then we're
going to look at my favorite game of the
year now this is very strange because my
favorite game of the year featured the
move of the year and when I showed the
game to Rex
earlier he found it so that doesn't make
any sense
so it's not my favorite game anymore
anyway hopefully we'll still be alive
next year out I doubt it
alright now this is a very long story
because I like stories also it kills
time for the video about a month ago
possibly two months ago I don't remember
I was in Georgia the one that's a
country and when I gave this in a kid's
lecture the kids like there's a country
in Georgia so he learned one thing in
the lecture that Georgia was a country
and I flew there from Georgia the true
story you guys at home already know this
okay and I stopped at Istanbul not
Constantinople and I even asked them why
is it that Constantinople and they said
that's nobody nobody's business but the
Turks so there you go anybody now you
got that Wow that's the only joke you're
ever going to get so they better laugh
it up now okay
so then he is someday he might be a
giant BAM did you get that one too good
if you didn't then you were lying before
all right now when I was in Georgia I
had four students three of them I knew
and one of they're like you want to work
with him and I'm like alright and he
used the world under 12 champion now so
and I gave a lecture about him last week
I don't know if it was recorded No ok so
there you go
and his name is Nikhil Kumar hopefully
he'll be here in February remarks
planning the norm term
if I have anything which I don't okay
and Nikhil plays the Carroll Khan which
I also play occasionally and in round
one of the norm tournament where I lost
all my games I actually found a game not
to lose so I could lecture about it then
the rest of the games you'll never see
it okay and that was against Tata of
Abraham Yin she decided to lose all of
her games to be nice to everybody now
when she plays in the US Women's Show in
all our games and went to $30,000 that's
that was a good idea she had okay we
don't win all your games are the women's
and lose them all when there's no prize
money I agree with that sentiment I
always tell my students when you're
playing for fun lose all your games that
when it's rated then when all your games
that way they get some win and lose
begin rating points every time okay
speaking of winning and losing rating
points Magnus Carlsen all right now
Tata have always plays efore and I
played her once in Chicago and I pled
the Sicilian so I'm not playing that
again and I decided to play the Carroll
Khan because I wanted to try to play
this line that I learned from my student
at the world cadet so if you're not
going to win chess games you might as
well steal your students ideas okay and
tots have and the caro-kann always
defends her upon by moving her knight
other moves re5 the advanced variation
and eat eggs d5 you could also play the
fantasy variation f3 breaking a very
important rule never play f3 okay anyway
she plug what she normally does and we
played the main main main main line of
the Carroll Khan probably there's eight
or nine thousand Grandmaster games in
this position and here white can choose
between Bishop f4 and Bishop to d2 in
previous games
she played Bishop to d2 and she did here
and the idea is white wants to Castle
queenside now in this position which
I've had before with black I play Queen
c7 and I've played Bishop e7 and those
are both normal moves and my student at
the world youth in Soviet Georgia he
suggested the move Bishop to
v6 now according to Akshay Andhra who I
just spoke to who lives down the block
he thinks white should play King b1 here
okay so when I play oxide rounder of
them he'll play King b1 and then we'll
see who's right
probably him and instead taught to have
played the normal move 94 although she
didn't know the move Bishop to d6 Bishop
to d6 is like the fourth most common
move in fact earlier in the year against
US Women's Champion Ossie Paquita Z nasi
played the move a5 and then she attacked
on the Queen side and taught to F should
have won but was a draw okay so Bishop
d6 Tata has ever faced before and I did
a lot of analysis of a pawn sacrifice
which I played later and after 94 we got
this position and if I was a better
player I would cheat and play Queen d5
okay
because Queen d5 you attack the a pawn
and maybe you'll trade Queens with
Queenie 4 but since Queen d5 is illegal
I played Bishop c7 and White has a move
that stops Queen d5 I can't hear you at
home so stop yelling at your computer
screen what's that g5 does not stop
Queen d5 so no c4 which is yeah see
there's the guys who watch my videos
right c4 and this is the mean move this
is the mainline although after Bishop d6
she was out of her prep and I cited this
position with Nikhil and by myself and
Nikhil explained as this pawn sacrifice
here d5 and law it looks at it a little
bit before the talks have game hoping
that it would happen and even though we
prepared this for several of Nikhil's
games where he did in fact play the
Carroll Khan he never got to this
position and I got to the position the
first time I played the Carroll Khan so
I showed him anyway
every grandmaster in the world here
plays the move king b1
following my rule always play king b1
and the idea is you trade on c4 and you
castle
white can take on c6 or play rook c1
first black plays rook to b8 and White's
King seems a little less safe than
blacks King blacks King seems pretty
safe and the pawn that I sacrificed
gives me an open file not today I was
playing Rex Sinquefield our chess club's
founder and one of the games he was down
a few pawns and even though it was
regular chess I think it was nine pawn
somehow not sure how anyway I told him
you're not really down pause just have
more open files so okay and black has
the nice d5 square for his Knight black
has a nice bishop on all these diagonals
I have an open line to her King she has
an isolated pawn and I've analyzed this
a fair bit and the computer says it's
about equal now Todd said wasn't
familiar with b5 and she played a
novelty because she didn't know the line
and she took on b5 that's never been
played before well has now hasn't been
played heretofore and in preparing for
this line analyzing it for my student
I wondered what happens if white takes
since nobody ever took and black of
course plays Queen d5 threatening to
take this upon two different ways and
threatening this pawn so I figured if
white wants to win material white should
take this pawn I would take this pawn
and White's upon a head so I don't know
if it was the day before my game
although I think it was or if it was in
Soviet Georgia I analyze this position
and the computer says blacks winning it
says I play Rick ba I play 95 I Castle
the c6 pawn is weak the b2 pawn is weak
and the King is weak so the computer
gives something like 1.4 for black okay
the computer says white should play King
b1 here which is what taught F played
and now I was on my own I figured if I
when my pawn back this should be good
for black and I actually have three ways
to win my pawn back or maybe four I
could take with the Queen I can take
with the pawn or I could check first
then the king would probably go to a1
and then take the pawn and the computer
wants me to do that it wants me to check
first force the King day one but instead
I took with the Queen and she traded
Queens and I didn't know if I should do
this or this
the reason is with the King on b1 I have
more moves later check like if my knight
comes in here sometimes I take things
with check and sometimes when I lose my
be pawn
I want her King on b1 the Kings on a1
it's further away from the action the
computer prefers that in any case the
computer prefers black for obvious
reasons let's see if somebody could give
me some of those obvious reasons why
should black have the advantage here
anyone you could put your hand down at
home
anybody Bueller why is black better more
queen well maybe that actually happened
later I wouldn't say it now but ended up
being the case
yeah my night can go to d5 or e4 g4 well
white as an isolated pawn which isn't
the greatest and also if no is the pawn
on h5 needs some babysitting this rook
is defending the pawn otherwise I'll
take it and even if my move my knight
away you move your rook away which is
what happened I can still try to win
your pawn later it's sitting on h5 so h5
is somewhat weak d4 pawn is isolated and
my knight is better than her Knight in
fact White's Knight has one good square
work in the white knight go there would
be a good square right now yeah II five
so I got rid of that I made sure that I
couldn't go to u5 and then I had no good
squares now my opponent made sure I
couldn't castle but more importantly she
didn't want her bishop being on these
silly squares so she played Bishop to b4
and the bishop can sit on c5 defending
this pawn attacking this pawn stopping
me from castling okay and I stopped 95
by playing my favorite move also known
as my least favourite move f6 okay
remember I have six as bad f5 is good
except here although I did play a5 later
so my Knights pretty good on d5 and it
can't really get harassed and her knight
I don't know on f3 can't go anywhere so
black has a nice advantage and well just
in general if you see an isolated pawn
and you see a knight in front of it just
better for the side with the knight and
one advantage to having an isolated pawn
especially in the center is your pawn is
defending these key squares in your
opponent's position but e 5 squared
doesn't matter because white can't play
95 and there's so few pieces on the
board I'm not concerned about my king
now one person I looked at the game with
and she was really impressed with this
game so we're getting married in two
weeks
that's very impressed she was like you
you played King f7 and King g7 why
didn't you castle of course castling is
illegal but that's okay I explained I
didn't want a castle and she was
confused she's like why wouldn't you
want a castle well in the endgame when
there's very few pieces left usually if
you cast Lee just start bringing your
King back to the center in this instance
there's two things white wants to do
either crush me on the C file or crush
me on the e-file now that I've weakened
d6 so King to d7 or f7 make a lot of
sense defending my e pawn and defending
the key squares and I want to connect my
rooks so I got to move my King off of Yi
and I would call the rest of the game an
endgame so we don't really have to look
at it for this lecture however I will
show you a double blunder because that's
fun
blundering is the most fun you can have
at some point in the game I decided I
was going to win and she decided she was
going to lose and actually this happened
another game of the tournament but that
didn't happen
um what I mean is if you looked at me
you'd be like wow he thinks he's
to win look at my opponent like wow they
think they're going to lose the reason
it happened in this game was I had
everything and extra material and I was
up like 20 minutes to one so when you
have one minute left and you're
completely lost your point has 20 you
expect to lose and the other game of the
tournament where this happened I was up
two pawns for nothing and my opponent
was like hmm should I resign and she
would make another move and then I hung
a piece so that came ended in a draw and
very suspicious fashion okay so later in
the game which wasn't interesting for
our lecture but interesting for the
double blunder these moves are all very
reasonable and in this position were
White's losing because White's not a lot
of material and has an unsafe King
she made a blunder in this position of
course White's already losing White's
down to pawns
White has no time on her clock and this
looks pretty annoying okay and here she
blundered with like 10 seconds left and
I didn't punish her because normally my
opponents don't give rooks away in
Grandmaster tournaments you and your
opponents and you at home give a rook
away even when you're not playing I
don't know how you do that okay you do
it
admit it okay right the people here are
like man I can't believe I did that I
was even playing I lost a truck and hear
my opponent played rook takes a four and
I played my plan which was to double
rooks that looks pretty good the reason
is it's pretty good but actually I can
win a whole rook here which is even
better who can raise their hand and
explain the winning sequence of moves
where black wins a whole rook also
winning the whole rook is good for those
of you at home see I told you can win at
rook and you couldn't find it no wonder
I couldn't
you have to break one of my rules I
don't break my rule so I couldn't find
it one of my rules is never I have a lot
of Nevers it's not f3 it's not f6 what
else could it be
never trade so I'm not trading for these
stupid rooks when I can double rooks on
the 7th so I didn't but if I do trade
rooks I would guess you would probably
take back and then if I check her I
would never check somebody's King off
the back row so I don't think of these
moves however that seems pretty good for
black yeah ok so that would have just
won the game immediately instead I
played rook c2 and I also won the game
immediately but not because I played
well because she made a mistake here to
confuse the issue and open by King she
should play that move d5 and the ideas
if I take then she can take and my king
is a little bit exposed everywhere she
can check me with her rooks and laughter
d5 the computer says I'm up something
like 1.3 if I had taken a rook I'd be up
everything she would resign instead of
d5 with seconds on her clock she took on
a6 and now there's no tricks left and
she resigned when she resigned and I
went downstairs and people were like you
won so I was checked for electronic
devices because they'd never seen me win
before that's okay I didn't win again
that was the only game I want in the
whole tournament and because I I stopped
cheating at that point and they were
like is there a maid here we're looking
for me and I was like I just want to
take this bishop and check and take upon
I'll be three or four pawns up I didn't
and I don't think there isn't me you
just win lots of pawns but I had no
intention of meeting my opponent because
that's that's not nice okay now that
game was like the appetizer for the game
of the year and the move of the year
okay and this is the game you all know
that means they don't know it
between Levon Aronian and Richard
rapport now it's funny about this is
when the world championship was going on
we were all falling asleep draw draw
draw there was a tournament here where
we did not fall asleep where everybody
was hanging all their Queens and there
was checkmate everywhere and somehow a
non-b everybody easily and in that
tournament
I was asked who should plan that
tournament and they said we have three
players we have Anand Cara Juan and
Nakamura the problem was during that
tournament and during the World
Championship there was a tournament
you've never heard of called the
European Club Cup and every grandmaster
the world was playing in that so to get
the fourth player they were like how
about him now he's playing in the
European Club Cup this went on for a
long time and I suggested Richard
rapport because of his interesting
entertaining style of play and then like
he's playing in the European Club Cup so
they ended up getting which fourth
player who was the fourth table very
good okay his top of this and play a lot
so he wasn't playing there but then we
drove a dump truck full of money up to
his house so now anything showed up okay
so uh during the anons debacle where he
crushed everybody and Fabiano Hikaru and
Topalov also played someone for some
reason and during the Carlsen car you
can match there was also this tournament
so there's a real boon in chess and the
funny thing about this game there was a
team that had mvl on board one he's
right like number three or four in the
world and Aronian on board too and they
both lost the same match so he's gotta
have some better players players aren't
good enough and this game richard
reports black now the reason we're poor
is good sort of like mvl is he never
plays for a draw he ever plays boring
fact he plays a little too interesting
so some of his tournaments he doesn't
get any points but he is rated about
twenty seven fifty so he must be winning
some games and he's only twenty
twenty-one years old and if he's younger
than that
apologize think he's 20 but you guys can
look it up I could correct it before he
yeah anyway he's one of the he's the top
junior in the world if he's still a
junior fighting with way II think
reports higher and he plays wild and
crazy and tries to win with both colors
now there's an unsound opening that I
play occasionally the chigorin and
Richard before play dead against
huronian showing he has no respect or
something and this position which I've
actually had he played it with I don't
know I dunno there's a line where you
take the knight and then play e5
but he played a five right away so he's
sacrificing a pawn to make the game
interesting the game was interesting and
he made a threat and I mean I would
never have this position with black as
blacks down upon it has no threats but
okay white has some weak pawns and black
has a nice Bishop to be developed where
his whites can't blacks ready to Castle
white isn't so black has compensation
for the pawn but again upon his appoint
in the game continued and Aronian did
something I would probably never
consider what I'm a pawn up and I'm
white I try to consolidate Aronian
unlike me tries to play the right move
okay
and sometimes when you try to play the
right move you're wrong play a bad move
and I like to play the most solid boring
slight advantage move so I don't get
into trouble and when you play the
correct move and sometimes you're wrong
then your moves are really bad and when
you're right then you would in 20 moves
so if I was white I would never win or
lose in 20 moves here I would win or
lose in 60 moves but Aronian he said I'm
a pawn up Black's not threatening when a
bad kid I have to play aggressive and
force the issue and he played that move
h4 not a move that I would consider okay
I would say hey my I haven't castled yet
I can't castle over here because there's
too much air over
here so I would develop my bishop
somewhere and then I would try to castle
okay so h4 was played and now Richard
rapport since he knew I'd be doing this
class the next month mastering the
middle game he wanted to give you guys a
middle game lesson and this is something
I explain all my students they never
listened to me so I give them the same
lesson again more money for me okay I'm
like do this they're like uh-huh uh-huh
just like Bill Murray and SNL and then
they don't do it and I told me Gunn
they're like oh yeah so you'll notice
black has castled and that white is not
because that happens about half the time
somebody castled somebody didn't and not
only did white not Castle white showed
no interest in castling he played h4
he's like I had Kings find on e1 and you
have to admit white does have a lot of
stuff in front of it next to his King
and black has nothing
so the King's pretty safe we have to
open up the center so instead of trying
to win this pawn with something like
Rick yay
which would weaken the f7 pawn so that
may be why would start attacking f7 he
attacked a five pot another way by
opening up the game and accepting the
fact that he would be down upon by
playing what move a move I would never
play f6 okay and obviously if I play F
II I'm winning my pawn back and I'm
opening up the F file and I'm attacking
the Queen choice so he took the pawn now
white is permanently a pawn ahead on the
other hand White's giving a Queen's tour
Queen a four Queen f4 move the Queen
again move all of our pawns never Castle
never move our rooks so Black has good
compensation Black has a nice pawn
structure black has everything out
except the bishop on c8 which is coming
out soon and permanently speaking I
don't know where White's King is
supposed to go now that there's open
files see when you blunder all your
pawns you have open files
okay Queen check King tucks away and
finally white decides all right I'll
castle
okay and of course we can't take the
bishop on d2 because our rook on f5 is
hanging our queen is actually doing
something here so rookie a queen c2 and
black has very good compensation for a
pawn for two reasons this Bishop is not
very good
to quote Lisa Simpson and whites played
that move h4 if I was white I would play
the move h4 to h2 or possibly h3 have to
think about it okay
and the bishop on CD 2 possibly could
improve later the pawn on h4 it's not
going back to age three age two that's a
permanent weakness and blacks pieces are
all great rook h5 g3 is a little too
weak it even for me giving away Knight
f3 and queen h3 so I wouldn't do that
Knight g3 attacking the rook rook d1 and
now materials equal and we luckily get
to see the move and the game of the year
in this position the rook is attacked
and Aronian played a very tricky move
and if you remember the famous game at
vikon's a between Aronian and andand
which I've also lectured on where Einon
played some of his preparation for the
World Championship match and being
Aronian with black and 23 moves and when
you play very interesting unusual
complicated chess occasionally you make
a big mistake and you lose the game
really quickly and when you don't make
mistakes then you win lots of games so a
rhodium was number two in the world for
a long time now he's hanging around
number seven and he's getting older and
the players who were very young like
rapport and Geary Caruana and so they're
getting older but to the right age not
like aronia so roan Ian here played the
very tricky move rook to d4 and he was
hoping after Bishop takes rook he would
take with the e pawn which unleashes the
white bishop to the black queen
and the pawn is attacking the knight on
e5 so he was like okay you can't take my
rook because that would unleash my
bishop and white would have a double
attack and well I don't play Bishop
takes rook it's not really clear what I
do here anyways I said earlier in the
lecture but you guys were probably
asleep I know they were
I showed this position to our chess club
founder Rex Sinquefield and I said here
black played the move of the year and he
thought about a minute and he played the
move so that's why when you do puzzles
at home you solve them all and then when
you go to a tournament you hang all your
pieces because then we do in a puzzle
people are telling you mate in one meet
and two how do you win when you play a
tournament nobody's telling you nothing
well except when I was playing TOC seven
cheating then computer was like do this
okay so in this position black played
one of the most amazing moves I've ever
seen and I'm sure you've all seen it
before because it's the game of the year
and most people don't beat Aronian with
black especially people you haven't
heard of richard rapport now you've
heard of them it's probably the last
move you would make that's a hint that's
why it's the move of the year you I'm
sure white didn't expect this move at
all it's the kind of move you see to
beginners tournaments where they don't
know how to play chess yet
very good we want a beginner you know
who to ask
right this class yeah yeah he actually
called Vegas and bet it was h1 because
yeah Rick h1 now White has two legal
moves and this is a forcing move check
is the most forcing move so you should
analyze it 9 h1 allows Knight f3 check
and now White has one legal move which
is to give his queen away so analyzing
that variation makes it seem like this
is good for black blacks up a queen and
whites night is on h1 and blacks whites
rook is attacked
okay so Aronian took with the king and
now after Bishop takes rook that very
issue we looked at earlier eat takes
attacking the Queen and the knight the
h4 square is vacated there is no roof
and now if we play e takes d4 we play
Queen h4 check Knight g4 and good luck
to you if you move the rook so your king
can get out I could check and then I
assume Queen takes Knight is winning I
could be wrong but I assume it is okay
and probably not only taking on f2 is
winning so probably just Queen takes
Knight is winning if that's not winning
then I don't want to be winning because
that's pretty winning okay so after
Bishop takes d4 Aronian who was probably
very surprised by rook h1 well there's
no material disparity here he gave his
rook away and they took a rook now
Black's threatening Queen h4 check and
Knight g4
so aronia broke my rule and the computer
doesn't like this move a three but that
does stop night g4 and now with Knight
g4 stopped white is threatening to take
the bishop two different ways so he
saved his bishop of course white black
could take the knight
Liuzza's bishop but black doesn't want
to trade pieces because White's king is
very suspicious so we want to keep a lot
of pieces on the board and looking at
this position even if white wasn't
getting checkmated White's pawn
structure is not very good and White's
Bishop isn't very good and White's King
isn't very safe and black has everything
even though material is equal Aronian
tried to escape by running his King to
the other side of the board and his King
was no safer over there now this is
another move that I like quite a bit
aronia wants to run his King away and
hide and repor wants to stop that at the
same time he'd like to play ninety three
track so what move did black play she
could do both of those things
rook da now moving the King is not good
illegal and Knight g3 is almost
impossible to stop and that's what
happened and now that the King is
running that way report gets his Queen
of the Queen side because there's no
defense to like Queen a4 check and Queen
b1 check and Queen takes a two and again
black sacrificed nothing and if you've
ever worked with yes or sara whan he
would say that black has a free attack
and that's an unusual thing that you're
attacking your opponent didn't sacrifice
anything in fact report tried to
sacrifice things but he didn't do it
he's even material he's trying to
sacrifice okay G for Aronian starts the
winning attack now Queen b5 with slight
threats very slight also Queen a4 is not
bad look we do it for mate so that's
even better than my other threat of the
Queen B one's meaner
okay so Queen G to the King is going to
escape if the Queen checks Knight B to
check oh the king is not going to escape
okay
King c2 9 c4 lots and lots of threats
Bishop c1
rip to defy really like this move
because when the Queen goes to a4 and
the King runs away we have another we
have another piece to attack with g5
here comes the meaning attack Knight a5
now we're threatening not just to win
the way I want it to win now we have
Queen d3 check rip b5 check and then
something to be 1 mate or night c4 mate
if the King goes to a3 so blacks
threading everything Queen a for winning
Queen d3 winning you play Bishop d2 and
after Queen d3 he resigned I put this
petition on my engine it said if you go
here or here it's made in three because
rugby 5 for example Kings c1 rugby 5
this is hard to stop
very hard to stop and King b2 doesn't
work either because of Queen c2
threatening Queen B to me again
impossible to stop in a legitimate way
you could stop it with an illegitimate
way but we didn't vote for Todd akin to
the state so anyone what as long as you
don't get it I'm good if you get them in
trouble alright good
they didn't get it alright so after
Queen d3 check the computer says King d1
is forced but the computer is wrong
because Aronian resigned so you don't
have to play King d1 after King G 1 9 c4
the computer says black is plus 11 with
the subtle threat Knight takes III check
not not good if you defend III that you
get checkmated in one also not good
okay so resigning was a good idea
computer recommended if you want to run
your King away so you play rookie one
defending the e3 pawn now your king can
run away and the truth hurts yeah so
resigning was a good idea but I like
this middle game because black started
attacking on the Kings side aronia moved
his King away so report will goes
because over the Queen side and remember
if you use all your pieces your attack
will work and that's the problem a lot
of people have they want to sacrifice
material and attack with one piece
because their opponents King is open but
if you attack with three or four or five
pieces your opponent's king is open by
force because you have so many pieces
attacking and here report used all his
pieces to attack the White King when the
King was on the Kings side and when the
King runs to the Queen side it didn't
find any safe haven a very nice game
from rapport winning with the black
pieces against somebody has been top ten
in the world for forever and if I can
complain a little bit then I'll get back
to my complaining but then about
something else for a second one of the
issues in chess which David Bronstein
complained about and he complained about
everything so that's not really saying
anything Braunstein didn't like the fact
that there's an insulation of the top
players for example you would assume
since you're all chess players that
you've played all the top players in the
world but you haven't and you would
think why mat grandmaster lecturing so
I've played dozens of games the top
players in the world I fled the top
players in the world
one-minute blitz chess and when they
were 11 years old okay but in slow
tournaments when they've gotten good
nope I've played Cara Juana I've played
Nakamura
I played Anand they were not top ten in
the world when I played him they weren't
top 20 in the world
they weren't top thirty in the world I
play them when they were like me or even
worse and then when they got good
they only play each other and when they
do that we see draw draw draw because
they know each other's opening is really
well their ratings are the same they
play safe and if you draw every game
you're writing doesn't change if you're
number five in the world and you lose
all your games now you're not number
five anymore but if you draw all your
games everybody you play is the same
rating then you everybody is the top ten
they just nobody gets in it's their own
Club so when you have tournaments like
this where the top ten top 20 players
play lower rated players then we get to
see exciting things we have to see lots
of decisive games lots of winning lots
of unusual openings that we don't
necessarily see when the top players
play each other in the long run players
were twenty seven hundred and twenty
seven twenty twenty seven forty will
lose to the top ten players in the world
and a long match but anyone game
thinking one with the black pieces and
play moves like rook h1 check that's
exciting for us so that's why they never
playing you know I'm going to do that
the crush them I've been waiting to play
rook h1 check forever since I saw this
game okay and they're like oh no Ben's
going to do that I got to play Carlsen
and draw I get my three rating points
terrible okay and that's why these guys
keep ducking me so I challenge the top
players in the world I dare you to play
me and if you accept that I'm sick that
day alright I hope you like mastering
the middle game I didn't want to make it
too hard so we just did it a master
level very simple any questions
seeing there's none I'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
you
[Music]